كيف تساعد الصين أوكرانيا
في أزمتها الخانقة؟
وماهي ردت فعل الغرب على ذلك؟
وكيف خدع الرئيس الصيني الغرب؟...
التحالف الذي يؤرق أمريكا ويهدد التحالفات
الغربية جميعها،
الصين وروسيا أصدقاء الأزمة
وألد أعداء الدول الغربية،
الأزمات تقرب الأصدقاء أكثر.
العقوبات الاقتصادية تضرب موسكو،
فظهرت بكين حليفة الاقتصاد الروسي،
فما الذي ستحتاجه روسيا إذا كانت الصين حليفتها؟
وبماذا يستطيع الغرب أن يهزوا
أوتاد الجبال الروسية المغروسة
تحت سور الصين العظيم،
اليوان الصيني سينقذ الروبل الروسي
في محنته لكن كيف ذلك؟
(خدعة صينية بيد أمريكية)...
في الوقت الذي تحاول أمريكا لملمة
وحلحلة تعقيدات الأزمة الروسية الأوكرانية
فهي تتخبط بالاستنجاد بالحلفاء،،،
وهنا قدمت استخباراتها على طبق من
ذهب للصينيين،،
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية تعلم مدى عمق
العلاقة بين بكين وموسكو لذلك طلبت
من الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ
محاولة ثني روسيا عن غزو أوكرانيا،،
فماذا كان رد الصينيين يا ترى؟
واشنطن قدمت طلباتها لبكين
لكن أصحاب العيون الضيقة لا يثقون بحسن نوايا
واشنطن،،، وهنا ولكي يبدي الأمريكان حسن نيتهم..
فقد قاموا بتقديم استخباراتهم وبنك معلوماتهم
عن الأزمة في الحدود الروسية الأوكرانية
وعن تجهيزات الجيش الروسي
والتوقعات التي ستحدث جراء الأزمة..
كل تلك المعلومات وصلت إلى موسكو بدون عناء،،
ليسجل الروس انتصارا على واشنطن
قبل حتى أن تبدأ الحرب... لكن
لماذا باعت بكين الأمريكان بهذه السهولة؟
السبب بسيط جدا يا سادة
أحد المتخصصين في الجامعات الأمريكية يقول:
إنه في برنامج ضخم لنقل التكنولوجيا، ساعد السوفييت
الصين في إنشاء 156 مؤسسة صناعية كبرى،
مع إرسال 11 ألف متخصص
في الفترة من 1954 إلى 1958.
وانتهت تلك الفترة من الصداقة الصينية الروسية
في أوائل الستينيات، وسط خلافات حول كيفية
مواجهة الولايات المتحدة، ولكن بعد
سقوط الاتحاد السوفيتي في عام 1991،
تحسنت العلاقات الصينية الروسية مرة أخرى،
حيث تعهد البلدان في عام 1996
ببناء "شراكة متساوية وموثوقة".
التقارب بين روسيا والصين يثير قلق
العواصم الغربية ممن تخشى تحالفا يقض
مضجع البيت الأبيض بشكل خاص،
وفق إعلام أمريكي..
فهل تقوى أمريكا على مواجهة الصين وروسيا
في آن واحد؟
من أجل مواجهة هذا الحلف الجديد تحتاج الولايات المتحدة
إلى حلفائها الأوروبيين لمواجهة الصين،
لأسباب اقتصادية في الغالب ولكن عسكريا أيضا.
لماذا تقارب التنين الصيني مع الدب الروسي؟
وسط مشهد انطلاق الألعاب الأولمبية الشتوية في بكين،
الذي استضاف فيه الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينج
نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين،
في لقاء هو الأول الذي يجمع بينهما وجهاً لوجه،
منذ مدة طويلة،...وكان هدف اللقاء
هو تحقيق التوازن مع ما وصفته الدولتان
بالتأثير "الخبيث" للولايات المتحدة في العالم
وإلى جانب التوافق السياسي التام لمواجهة أنشطة
واشنطن "الخبيثة"، كشفت القمة الصينية- الروسية
عن ميلاد تحالف استراتيجي غير مسبوق
في مجال الطاقة. إذ اتفق الرئيسان الصيني والروسي
على صفقات بمئات المليارات من الدولارات
في مجالي الغاز والبترول
هل تغني تجارة الصين روسيا عن التجارة الغربية؟
في ظل عقوبات اقتصادية قاسية على موسكو،
خرجت التقارير لتقول، أن حجم التجارة بين بكين وموسكو
بلغ 150 مليار دولار في العام ٢٠٢١،
هذه التجارة المتنامية أبعدت روسيا عن الدولار،
ومثّل اليوان الصيني 17% من تسويات التجارة بينهما..
بينما عززت موسكو الاحتياطي النقدي
ليصل 640 مليار دولار،
نصف الاحتياطات الروسية مقومة بالدولار واليورو
و20% بالذهب، و13% باليوان،
مع ذعر الأسواق انهار الروبل وفقد20% من قيمته،
فسمحت بكين باستيراد نفط موسكو وقمحها،
فهل يكفي اليوان  لمساعدة الروبل؟..
كيف سيستفيد الروس من الصين؟
* الصين تصنع نسخة من كل شيء
(إن لم تجد الدواء فيوجد لدينا البديل
كما يقول أصحاب الصيدليات يا عزيزي)
*حتى أن الصين صنعت طائرات حربية
مطابقة لطائرات أمريكية،
*لن تعجز الصين عن جعل روسيا تواكب
تكنولوجيا الغرب وإنهاء الحظر الأوروبي
*عقوبات الغرب لحرمان روسيا من التكنلوجيا
لا يفيد بشيء وكذلك عدم شراء الغاز الروسي،
فالصين ستشتري غازها من موسكو وذلك سيكون
كافياً لروسيا،
* لجوء الغرب لغاز ونفط الخليج عوضا عن ما تصدره
روسيا لهم لن ينفع أيضا فالخليج يرفض
أن يدخل في هذه الحسبة ولا يريد عداوة
روسيا والصين بجانبها..
*وهكذا استعان بوتين بالصين...
حتى أنه أمن اليوان الصيني بالذهب قبل الحرب..
خلاصة الوضع الحالي:
الصين حليف استراتيجي قد يكتفي الروس
بتحالفهم معها، فالسلاح الروسي والصناعة
والتكنولوجيا الروسية تكفي لمجابهة العالم بأسره،
لكن هذا الحلف لن ينحصر على هذين الطرفين فقط
فمجنون كوريا الشمالية متأهب وسينضم للحلف
بل أنه هو من سيطلب الانضمام ولن ينتظر
أن يُطلب منه ذلك، وهنا ستكون الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية في مأزق حقيقي، فهم لم يستطيعوا
تنفيذ قراراتهم على كيم وهو وحيد يغني خارج السرب
فما بالنا لو انضم لحلف موسكو وبكين،،
يا لقوة هذا الحلف، لكن مهلا الحلف لم يكتمل بعد
فإيران الدولة النووية لن تترك أصدقاءها
وكأن شيئا لم يكن،
فيصبح حلفا رباعيا لا يقهر بانتظار حلفاء جدد
قد لا يزيدون من قوة الحلف الرباعي فقط
بل سيزعزعون قوة الخصوم...
فهل يعني هذا انتهاء أسطورة
اسمها الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية؟